one of the economic and cultural changes
that we've seen pretty dramatically in
the last few decades is the share of
lung young adults who never leave home
even after they go through their
schooling or at some point in their
young lives boomerang back home and we
estimate that more than 40% nearly half
of all Millennials have either never
never left never launched if you will or
at some point have boomerang back home
if you can't find a job if you're if
you're underemployed if you're at a
non-paying internship all those sorts of
journeys mom and dad's home ain't bad
place to hang out you know the
refrigerator is usually Stockton you
don't have to put coins in the laundry
and interestingly I think there was in
my generation there was some stigma
attached to that you know you know with
your life already for goodness sake you
know we've done some surveying of both
the parents of such young adults and
young adults themselves looking for
tension within those homes looking for a
conflict looking for stigma and frankly
we don't find that much in part because
it has become more commonplace and
people sort of understand yeah that's
that's that's the nature of the slow
passage into adulthood
you know there are societies in the
world and and southern Europe
particularly Italy come to mind where
culturally young men have been living
with their mothers you know and into
their 30s and 40s of bambo Chianti is
big baby and mommy SMO is mama's boy and
some of this is cultural some of this is
clearly economic and and Europe frankly
has the same challenges with not enough
jobs for young adults that we have so a
lot of the world is is is going through
this I think this the silver lining is
that there don't seem to be a lot of
stresses again I speak as a baby boomer
who came of age in the 60s and there was
a whiff of generation war in the air it
was a time when there was a
women's rights movement civil rights
movement anti-war protests there was a
feeling that the older generation had
screwed everything up and thank God here
we were to make everything right there
was almost a sort of a finger of
accusation pointed at the older
generation you see virtually none of
that with within the younger generation
in some ways I have a sense from our
surveys that young adults have sort of
seamlessly migrated from being the
children of their parents in many cases
to being the roommates of their parents
and they have the similar interest and
they text each other and they get on
with their lives
and there's a certain sort of resilience
there that's a snapshot of a moment you
know in this slower passage to adulthood
again I don't think we we yet know
fast-forwarding a decade or two down the
road what that will mean what that will
mean for the family formations of these
young adults I suspect what it does mean
is that the intergenerational
interdependence that we see in these
families is likely to last there is
there's no question that families stay
closer to each other
farther into the life cycle than may
have been the case in the past and when
we talk about generational personalities
let's acknowledge up front we are deep
into the realm of generalization and
stereotype and there are within any
generation there as many differences
between individuals as there are across
generations and the idea that if you're
born in one year you're a member of one
generation and therefore have one part
of personality but you were born a year
later you're another generation that
flies in the face of common sense
obviously having said that you can look
at broad patterns and we can see this
with our attitudinal data our voting
behavior our economic circumstances and
again accepting accepting the caveat
that these are big generalizations there
are there are a number of things that do
stand out in terms of the person persona
of this generation one of them is a
wariness there is a classic question in
social science about what we call social
trust and the question goes very simply
generally speaking would you say most
people can be trusted or you can't be
too careful when you're dealing with
other people we the Pew Research Center
and other research organizations
been asking this question for 40 years
and we have never seen a generation that
is as low on social trust as Millennials
are so only about 19% of Millennials the
last time we asked this question say
yeah most people can be trusted it's a
very interesting finding because
Millennials are also a play nicely with
other generation I think you know we all
got that report card in kindergarten
plays nicely with others I think
Millennials must have all done very well
on that how do you square these two
seemingly opposite characteristics I'm
not for anything I'm not sure I can but
let me let me put forward a couple of
interesting theories to start with the
social trust finding one of the things
that sociologists know and psychologists
have observed is that population groups
within a population that feel vulnerable
for whatever reason tend to be low on
social trust because they're not well
fortified to deal with the consequences
of misplaced trust so if you think about
the Millennial Generation and you think
about the demographic characteristics a
large share are non-white and a large
share at the lower end of the
socio-economic scale in both cases you
know that places them or may place them
in in an attitude of vulnerability and
therefore you can't be too careful
I think it's possible that the fact that
they navigate they do so much of their
social interaction online may lead to a
wariness it's one thing to have
face-to-face friends and those sorts of
relationships where you can you have a
history of people you can read body
language you can do all the things that
friends tend to do when you have
relationships that are entirely mediated
through and through an online setting
it's more complicated and I think people
come around to the view that not
everybody's exactly who they say they
are online a final possibility is the
way the very nurturing parenting norms
that raised Millennials the Millennials
came of age in the 90s and arts in an
era of global terrorism
of domestic school shootings Columbine
9/11 a lot of pretty horrible things
that are particularly disturbing to
parents the worry about strangers online
online predators and all the rest social
psychologists would say that they have
been raised in a very protective
nurturing environment if there's a kind
of an everybody gets a trophy quality to
the way Millennials have been raised
you're precious
it's a mean and difficult world I need
to protect you which may then be picked
up by by the children raised this way as
you better be careful you better be wary
again I wouldn't push this too far but
but one real-world consequence that is
already observable among the Millennials
is in their economic behaviors they
appear to be a risk-averse generation
now maybe that's because they don't they
don't have money they don't have the
Economic Security that leads to a
freedom to take risks or maybe maybe
it's the way they've been raised but one
of the data points is you know fidelity
and other companies that manage 401ks
and kind of have a sense of the
investment habits and patterns of
millions and millions of people who work
have noticed in the last five or six
years that the young adults in these in
these 401k programs when they look at
their investment choices and you know
the advice to the young adults is be a
little bit you you know you're young you
have time be aggressive you know a stock
portfolio over the long haul they're
supposed to do better etc etc many young
adults are not taking that advice I
think you can see that in their
consumption habits as well again either
because they don't have the money or
they don't want to take on the debt
they're not buying cars they're not
buying houses and I think there is a
kind of wariness that cuts across a lot
of the dimensions of their lives
you